der shinkansen ist eine japanische
legende
sowas gibt es nur einmal auf der welt
er pusht die wirtschaft und begeistert
seine fans
ich liebe den zehnkampf in
den rauen terry bei schlechtem wetter
und sogar bei erdbeben
einer meiner schlimmsten erinnerungen
wann fängt elli wilson erforscht was ihn
so sicher und effizient macht ich will
mehr über die bahnbrechenden und teils
geheimen technologien erfahren die den
shinkansen zum liebling jedes zug fans
machen
tokios hauptbahnhof
einer der geschäftigsten
verkehrsknotenpunkte der welt und
stadtbahnhof fast aller shinkansen
linien
eben tag gehen hier eine halbe million
menschen ein und aus viele von ihnen
sind pendler
ohne den shinkansen könnte ich meinen
job nicht machen
mit 285 kilometern pro stunde ist der
shinkansen gut doppelt so schnell wie
normale eisenbahn
das hat ihm den spitznamen bullet train
eingebracht vom englischen wort für
gewehrkugel
[Musik]
die metropolregion von tokio ist mit 37
millionen einwohnern die größte der welt
dementsprechend voll sind die straßen da
lassen fiel das auto in der garage und
nehmen lieber den shinkansen
heidi freut mich gleichfalls
domenica ist kultur übersetzer für
ausländische studenten er wird teddy
wilson auf seiner reise begleiten
wie kaufe ich ein ticket zuerst sitze
reserviert
wir sitzen zusammen
es geht um die moscheen ganzen strecke
betrieben von japans central railway bei
ihrer eröffnung 1964 war sie die erste
schnellfahrstrecke der welt
die ingenieure mussten sich etwas
einfallen lassen das schienennetz liegt
nämlich in einem erdbebengebiet auf
der 500 kilometer langen fahrt von tokio
nach osaka liegt der shinkansen mehrere
zwischenstopps ein vielleicht kann
wilson dort die geheimnisse des ballett
trains lüften
in japan geht man jedoch nicht
unvorbereitet auf reisen
für die fahrt brauchen sie auf jeden
fall ein eckball was empfehlen sie
weggeben bedeutet bahnhofs essen zum
mitnehmen für japaner auf reisen ein
absolutes muss mögen sie fest es gibt so
schien
die abgepackten mahlzeiten sind lecker
und praktisch
essen für die reise
überall verkaufsautomaten
noch ein erfrischendes getränk ziehen
schnell pünktlich effizient hier muss
jeder arbeitsschritt sitzen
auch die 55 reinigungskräfte dürfen sich
keinen fehltritt erlauben
[Musik]
innerhalb von nur acht minuten müssen
sie rund
1100 sitze für die neue fahrt
vorbereiten
das bedeutet in fahrtrichtung drehen
abbürsten
und abdecken
es gibt keinen spielraum für fehler wenn
der zug abfährt muss alles blitzsauber
sein ein echt enger zeitplan
wir haben nur sehr wenig zeit wir müssen
also sehr effizient arbeiten
während die putzkräfte schuften
schwärmt lokführer rio sarah von seinem
job wie ist das für sie diesen zug zu
steuern
alle lieben den schimpansen und ich darf
ihn fahren das ist eine große ehre und
das freut mich sehr
an einem sechsstündigen arbeitstag liegt
como sarah etwa 1000 kilometer zurück
es ist eine herausforderung
es gibt viel zu lernen und viel zu
beachten
ist dass unser den kanzeln der mit dem
wir heute fahren ja ok perfekt dann
hatte ich sie nicht weiter auf vielen
dank
er muss los das ist unser zug
der n7 100 anna gehört zu den neuesten
shinkansen modellen er ist 400 meter
lang und bietet platz für 1300
passagiere
angetrieben wird er mit elektrischem
strom jeder räder satz hat einen eigenen
motor der shinkansen fährt also
sozusagen mit allradantrieb damit er
ohne zu wenden in beide richtungen
fahren kann gibt es an beiden enden
einen führer raum
mit dem auto dauert die fahrt von tokio
nach osaka mehr als sechs stunden
mit dem bullet train sind es nur zwei
stunden und 22 minuten
die japaner liegen wert auf ruhe
unterhalten wird sich höchstens ganz
leise
lokführer ryosuke fährt los
nach nur zwei minuten erreicht der
shinkansen seine höchstgeschwindigkeit
von 285 kilometern pro stunde
wir sind unglaublich schnell aber man
merkt es kaum die fahrt ist sehr
angenehm
was ihn so schnell macht sind seine
windschnittige form und das leichte
material seiner aluminium karosserie
wiegt nur etwa halb so viel wie die von
normalen zügen außerdem hat er ein
eigenes gleis er muss also nie auf
langsamere züge warten
mit der zeit bekommt man ein gefühl für
die geschwindigkeit
und der allradantrieb sorgt für
hervorragende bodenhaftung
recht schnell
dutzende ganzen züge fahren auf
demselben gleis um kollisionen zu
vermeiden müssen sie mindestens einen
kilometer abstand halten
in der zentrale in tokio achtet ein team
von technikern darauf dass diese vorgabe
auch eingehalten wird
unser kontrollzentrum in tokio ist das
gehirn des shinkansen
hier läuft alles zusammen
dahinter steckt ein system namens
automatik train control
sensoren entlang der strecke sammeln
daten zur geschwindigkeit und position
jedes zuges und übermitteln sie in
echtzeit als kontrollzentrum
die automatische zu kontrolle oder etc
berechnet jederzeit wo die einzelnen
züge sind und wie schnell sie fahren
dürfen
wenn einer zu schnell fährt aktiviert
die etc automatisch die bremsen
das system zu überwachen ist eine
verantwortungsvolle aufgabe
wenn etwas unvorhergesehenes passiert
kann es auch schon mal stressig werden
wir haben waren systeme für jeden
erdenklichen notfall zum beispiel für
erdbeben
sobald unsere sensoren eine
erschütterung im boden wahrnehmen geht
in unserer zentrale der alarm los
der shinkansen hat eine einzigartige
sicherheitsbilanz
[Musik]
es gab noch keinen einzigen tödlichen
unfall
nicht mal während eines schweren
erdbebens
im schnitt gibt es in japan pro jahr
mehr als 1000 erdbeben zu wissen wie man
reagieren muss ist überlebensnotwendig
[Applaus]
höchste zeit sich im erdbeben zentrum
von tokyo genauer zu informieren
hier werden leute auf erdbeben
situationen vorbereitet
einheimische und touristen lernen wie
man sich im ernstfall richtig verhält
[Musik]
zum glück erklärt das tablet alles
normal auf englisch
da steht es gab ein erdbeben und wir
müssen drei tage ohne hilfe überleben so
lange dauert es bis die rettungskräfte
zu uns vordringen
auf geht's in den simulator
[Musik]
hier haben sie einen zerstörten
häuserblock nachgebaut
sieht schlimm aus
eine umgeknickte straßenlaterne
die ampel ist auch in gefallen
für eine simulation fühlt es sich ganz
schön echter jemand ruft hilfe helfen
sie mir brände sind ein großes problem
oder ja nach erdbeben gibt es überall
feuer
noch mehr schaden genau
wo waren sie während des erdbebens vom
ich saß in einem café in tokio erdbeben
dauern normalerweise weniger als eine
minute
und dieses mehr als zwei glaube ich war
echt nervös
ist stärker geworden
stärker und stärker
irgendwann kam die kellnerin zu mir und
meinte sie müssen hier raus
das wasser
während eines erdbebens möchte niemand
in einem fahrenden
hochgeschwindigkeitszug sitzen
japans bahn ingenieure haben für diesen
fall vorgesorgt
sensoren entlang der strecke
registrieren die frühesten anzeichen
eines erdbebens
wir haben 21 messpunkte entlang der
strecke tokio shinkansen installiert sie
erfassen das erdbeben ab der ersten
welle wenn die zugstrecke betroffen ist
werden wir sofort alarmiert
der alarm zeigt an dass die stromzufuhr
an den oberleitungen abgestellt wird
sobald das erdbeben losgeht halten also
alle züge in der region automatisch an
spezielle leid schienen sorgen dafür
dass sie dabei in der spur bleiben und
falls das nicht ausreicht waren stopper
an der unterseite den zug davor
umzukippen
im märz 2011 stellt ein schweres
erdbeben im nordosten japans das system
auf eine harte probe
es erreicht einen wert von 9,0 auf der
richterskala und dauert sechs minuten
fast 20.000 menschen sterben die schäden
gehen in die milliarden
alle 50 züge auf der tokyo schien ganzen
linie befinden sich in der erdbebenzone
doch das system funktioniert tadellos
zehn sekunden vor dem hauptbeben kommen
alle züge zum stehen
kein einziger türkei durch den ganzen
zug ist bei dem beben 2011 entgleist
kein anderer hochgeschwindigkeitszug der
welt hat einer so makellose bilanz wie
der shinkansen und das schon auch so
bleiben
sicherheit hat bei uns höchste priorität
die bahn mitarbeiter rufen und
gestikulieren permanent
es gehört zu ihrer arbeit dazu
wir benutzen unsere augen unsere finger
und unsere stimmen damit sorgen wir
dafür dass der zugbetrieb sicher läuft
laut eines japanischen
forschungsinstituts machen menschen
deutlich weniger fehler wenn körper und
geist zusammenarbeiten
die reise auf der tokyo shinkansen linie
geht weiter
eine stunde südwestlich von tokio ist
das gemuese
temporal tempora ach so
lecker alt empora
super
[Musik]
der schinken bietet jede menge hightech
und die muss aufwendig gewartet werden
in einer hochmodernen werkstatt zwischen
tokio und osaka
[Musik]
nächster halt hamamatsu
dieser zug fährt gerade zur wartung in
die hamamatsu reparatur station
dabei muss er einen bahnübergang
überqueren
den einzigen auf der gesamten strecke
alle drei jahre oder nach 1,2 millionen
kilometern wird jeder bullet train
komplett überholt die aufsicht hat
werkstattleiter masako tanaka
wir entkoppeln die waggons und nähmen
jeden einzelnen auseinander dann
überprüfen wir die karosserie das
fahrgestell und alle anderen teile wenn
wir fertig sind bauen wir alles wieder
zusammen
[Musik]
zuerst werden die schwer beanspruchten
räder kontrolliert
wir nehmen jetzt die räder ab dann
überprüfen wer sie auf schäden und
katzer
damit wir dabei nicht übersehen benutzen
wir ein ultraschallgerät
die räder von hochgeschwindigkeitszügen
sind täglich großen belastungen
ausgesetzt
selbst vermeintlich kleine schäden
können katastrophen verursachen beim
zugunglück von eschede im jahr 1998
bringt ein gebrochenes rat einen
vollbesetzten ic zum entgleisen über 100
menschen kommen ums leben man kann also
gar nicht gründlich genug sein
[Musik]
mit ihrem ultraschallgerät spüren die
techniker selbst aller feinste risse auf
danach überprüfen sie die form der räder
schon kleinen dellen oder verformungen
müssen sofort behoben werden
sie können während der fahrt vibrationen
auslösen die sich aufschaukeln und den
zug zum entgleisen bringen
jedes rad muss dieselbe größe haben bis
auf den hundertstel millimeter
wer es hier nicht so genau nimmt hat den
falschen job
nach der inspektion werden die räder an
das drehgestell montiert an dem auch die
scheibenbremsen sitzen
jede bremse wird so ausgerichtet dass
sie exakt an der richtigen stelle greift
bei dieser arbeit darf den technikern
kein fehler unterlaufen
[Musik]
für einen zug so randvoll mit hightech
wird erstaunlich vieles in handarbeit
erledigt
auf den 1300 technikern lastet ein hoher
druck
der shinkansen fährt extrem schnell wenn
sich irgendwo eine mutter oder eine
schraube löst könnte das katastrophale
folgen haben
um konzentriert zu bleiben nutzen die
techniker dieselbe methode wie die
schaffner und zugführer sie rufen und
gestikulieren
mit augen und ohren stellen wir sicher
dass jedes teil exakt sitzt das ist sehr
wichtig für die sicherheit des
shinkansen
ein gebäude weiterbringen techniker die
elektroniker vordermann
[Musik]
hier sehen sie den antrieb der zug fährt
so schnell dass er ein spezielles
kontrollsystem braucht
[Musik]
das system verteilt den strom aus der
oberleitung
gleichmäßig auf die motoren
wie das genau funktioniert bleibt
allerdings ein geheimnis
können wir nicht heran
nein tut mir leid
das geht leider nicht
unsere technologie ist geheim
bitte halten sie abstand
etwa zwei wochen dauert es einen zug
komplett zu überholen und ihn zurück
aufs gleis zu bringen
[Musik]
ich liebe meinen job ich sorge dafür
dass die leute jeden tag mit dem
shinkansen sicher ans ziel kommen das
ist eine tolle aufgabe
die makellose sicherheitsbilanz des
schinkens hin kommt nicht von ungefähr
dahinter steckt ein haufen arbeit
pläne für einen hochgeschwindigkeitszug
gibt es in japan schon ende der 30er
jahre
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg nehmen sie
konkrete formen an eine bessere
vernetzung soll der schwer geschädigten
wirtschaft wieder auf die beine helfen
ingenieure japanischer kampfjets liefern
das design sie wollen einen zug bauen
der sich wie ein flugzeug anfühlt
1964 ist es soweit die schimpansen linie
wird eröffnet sie bringt neue arbeiter
in japans städte und beschert dem land
den ersehnten wirtschaftlichen
aufschwung
[Musik]
ist der shinkansen auf dauer nicht
langweilig
er ist einfach toll
[Musik]
die japaner lieben ihren shinkansen
ob in echt
oder als miniaturausgabe im museum
diese modell landschaft ist fantastisch
sie haben die komplette tokio linie
nachgebaut
hier vorne ist tokio dann kommt mount
fuji danach hamamatsu mit der großen
shinkansen werkstatt nagoya und ganz am
schluss osaka die details sind echt cool
im miniatur wunderland dauert einen tag
nur 15 minuten kaum ist es dunkel wird
es auch schon wieder hell
was gefällt euch am shinkansen am besten
alle sind sich einig das tollste am
tanzen ist sein rasantes tempo
für echte bahnfans wurde diese alte
bahnhof zwischen den gleisen in ein cafe
verwandeln
an beiden seiten rasen züge vorbei für
sie als fan gibt es keinen besseren ort
für eine tasse kaffee oder ja es ist
wirklich ziemlich cool alex sims ist
extra aus australien angereist um seinen
lieblings zug in aktion zu erleben
ich mache gerne videos von ihm andere
messen seine geschwindigkeit da ist
einer es gibt auch listen zum ankreuzen
den hatte ich schon und den
für leute wie sims wird der shinkansen
nie langweilig
die signale die bahnhofs ansagen die
erschütterung des bahnsteigs wenn ein
zug über oder unter einem vorbeifährt es
ist eine erfahrung die den ganzen körper
anspricht man spürt die vibration sieht
die hellen lichter und steigt zum
schluss selbst in den zug
an jedem bahnsteig warten fans auf den
perfekten schnappschuss mit ihrer ikone
bitte lächeln
mit gut geworden
ich habe heute frei da habe ich mir
gedacht ich zeige meinen sohn mal einen
ganz besonderen zug
der zug der gleiche ein pferd steht bei
den kindern hoch im kurs
man sieht ihn nur selten darum ist es
immer ein tolles erlebnis
da konnte der
knallgelbe zug macht seinem namen alle
ehre doktor kommt nur alle 10 tage
vorbei er fährt auf derselben route wie
der tokyo shinkansen
drinnen sitzen allerdings keine
fahrgäste sondern techniker die die
fahrbahn überprüfen super auf geht's
ein bahnmitarbeiter führt ins innere des
zuges das vollgestopft ist mit
elektronik
[Musik]
eine crew aus sieben technikern sucht
jeden zentimeter strecke nach fehlern ab
die gleise genauso wie die oberleitungen
[Musik]
wahnsinn
michael thurk obayashi leitet das team
wie können sie bei einer geschwindigkeit
von fast 300 kilometern pro stunde
überhaupt wasser kennen
spezielle sensoren unter dem zug tasten
das gleis mit laserstrahlen ab wenn
etwas nicht stimmt melden die es der
leitzentrale in tokio und die stelle
wird sofort repariert
der laser registriert unregelmäßigkeiten
die so klein sind wie ein stecknadelkopf
auf ähnliche weise werden die
oberleitungen kontrolliert die den zug
mit strom versorgen in ihnen herrscht
eine spannung von
25.000 volt
sieht aus wie ein kapitäns stuhl ist es
aber nicht hier sitzt der inspektor der
die oberleitungen überprüft den großteil
seiner arbeit macht allerdings
heutzutage diese kamera
die kamera sendet ihre bilder in
echtzeit an die monitore der techniker
diese wiederum suchen nach defekten die
einen stromausfall auslösen könnten
wir überprüfen die leitungen auf
abnutzungserscheinungen wenn sie sehr
lange in betrieb sind können sie
irgendwann den werden und reißen dann
hat der shinkansen keinen strom mehr
jedes problem wird sofort gemeldet und
behoben
für viele japaner ist doktor yellow ein
superheld alle lieben ihn es gibt ein
sprichwort wer doch carlo sid lebt ein
glückliches leben das freut uns
natürlich
yellow hat feierabend aber auf den
gleisen geht die arbeit jetzt erst
richtig los
[Musik]
von mitternacht bis sechs uhr morgens
wenn keine züge unterwegs sind schuften
hier 3.000 wartungsarbeiter
wir prüfen was dr yellow gefunden hat
dann legen wir los
heute schüttelt das team an einem
streckenabschnitt neue steine auf
die strecke muss perfekt eben sein da
haben wir ganz genaue vorgang
bis tagesanbruch sind die reparaturen
abgeschlossen
doch manche störungen lassen sich nicht
so leicht beheben
alles dreht sich um geschwindigkeit
effizienz und pünktlichkeit
aber eine sache kann das system so
richtig durcheinander bringen
das wetter
bei schneestürmen muss auch der
shinkansen passen
herzog an der bahnstrecke 21 ist außer
betrieb bitte nicht einsteigen
hallo hier ist die zentrale
jetzt muss die leitstelle aktiv werden
wie sind die wetterbedingungen
der fahrtwind sorgt den schnee unter den
zug und lässt ihn dort verreisen wenn
die ice brauchen sich lösen und gegen
die waggons fliegen können sie schwere
schäden und sogar unfälle verursachen
da hilft nur eins runter mit der
geschwindigkeit aus dem bullet train
wird ein bummelzug
mittlerweile hat die japanische bahn
einen weg gefunden das problem zumindest
abzumildern
sprinkleranlage spritzen warmes wasser
auf die strecke und verhindern so dass
der schnee am zug festfriert
[Musik]
bei gutem wetter ist der shinkansen
nicht aufzuhalten weiter geht es nach
nagoya
der ausblick ist genial überall berge
und der da ist mit abstand der
beeindruckensten der vulkan fuji
jede menge berge das bedeutet für den
zugverkehr jede menge tunnel
[Musik]
ich glaube dass es der längste bislang
ja stimmt
alleine auf der tokyo strecke gibt es 66
tunnel der längste von ihnen misst acht
kilometer
das dauert eine weile
für hochgeschwindigkeitszüge wie den
schimpansen sind tunnels war praktisch
aber sie schaffen auch probleme genauer
gesagt lärm
der zug schiebt einer druckwelle vor
sich her die sich bei der fahrt durch
den tunnel mit einem lauten knall
entlädt dem sogenannten tunnel knall um
dieses problem zu lösen haben die
ingenieure die schnauze des shinkansen
flach und stromlinienförmig gemacht sie
schneidet durch die luft wie ein messer
und baut so weniger druck auf
über die jahre hat sich die form des
shinkansen dramatisch verändert
innovationen wie die spitze schnauze
abgedeckte räder und vibrationsdämpfung
de doppel wende reduzieren den
luftwiderstand und sorgen für mehr
leistung
sogar die stromabnehmer wurden
aerodynamik optimiert
er fährt sehr ruhig das ergebnis mehr
tempo bei weniger stromverbrauch
[Musik]
toll
japans dicht bevölkerte städte
profitieren immens von diesen
verbesserungen denn je schneller die
züge sind desto häufiger fahren sie
doch die geschwindigkeit darf nicht auf
kosten der sicherheit gehen denn dann
kann die fahrt schnell in einer
katastrophe enden
[Musik]
2013 ereignet sich im spanischen
santiago de compostela ein tragisches
unglück
einzug fast doppelt so schnell wie
erlaubt in einer kurve und entgleist 79
menschen sterben die chefs von central
japan railway
investieren viel geld um solche unfälle
zu vermeiden
erfahren gerade eine kurve aber obwohl
wir fast 300 sachen drauf haben spürt
man es kaum die ingenieure des
schimpansen haben nämlich alles dafür
getan die zentrifugalkraft zu überlisten
versteckt in den hügeln vor der stadt
nagoya liegt das koki forschungszentrum
[Musik]
auf diesem streng bewachten gelände
entstehen die innovationen die den
shinkansen so erfolgreich machen
die arbeit ist so geheim dass wir fast
nirgendwo filmen dürfen aber immerhin
wollen sie uns erklären wieso der
shinkansen so geschmeidig um die kurve
fährt
dazu ihrer kadima ist stellvertretender
leiter des forschungszentrums die
herausforderung möglichst viele
informationen aus ihm heraus zu locken
wie viele mitarbeiter haben sie
fast alle wissenschaftler
90 davon
ganz schön finde nur wo sind sie und
vorarbeiten die oder da geheim geheim
gehalten daheim geheim wir dürfen nichts
filmen
es hat fünf jahre gedauert und mehr als
zwei milliarden dollar gekostet einer
technologie zu entwickeln die den
shinkansen sicher um die kurve bringt
ihr name body in klein system
dieser simulator wurde gebaut um die
effekte von hochgeschwindigkeits kurven
fahrten zu testen
wilson probiert ihn aus
[Musik]
wie schnell sind wir
270 kilometer pro stunde
zuerst fahren wir ohne body in kleinster
wenn das system ausgeschaltet ist drückt
die fliehkraft die männer zur seite
jetzt geht es mit 270 um die kurve
ok los geht's
ich spüre es
damit fahrgäste möglichst wenig von den
fliehkräften spüren sind
eisenbahnschienen in kurven etwas nach
innen geneigt doch
hochgeschwindigkeitszüge müssen sich
tiefer in die kurve legen als normale
züge
jetzt fahren wir mit body in kleinster
die japanischen ingenieure haben dafür
eine praktische lösung gefunden
statt das gleis zu neigen neigen sie
einfach den zug
computergesteuerte federn kippen die
waggons in kurven nach innen jeder
waggon neigt sich im richtigen winkel
und zum richtigen zeitpunkt
jetzt kommt die kurve
man merkt zwar dass es um die kurve geht
aber das glas ist kein stück gerutscht
und ich auch nicht
dank body in klein system fährt der
shinkansen schnell sicher und
komfortabel um die kurve
wie lange haben sie daran geforscht
eine sehr lange zeit
und was kommt als nächstes
das ist streng geheim
als passagier im schanzen kriegt man
nicht mit wie so ein bullet train
gesteuert wird
im simulator des bauernmuseums von
nagoya darf jeder besucher mal lokführer
spielen
[Musik]
die leitstelle sagt ich soll 285 fahren
ich bin bei 210
also schneller
die futuristische nase die vielen knöpfe
es fühlt sich ein bisschen an wie in
einem raumschiff
275 gleich haben wir es
als 285 greift die automatische zu
kontrolle ein und verhindert dass ich
noch schneller werden
wie im echten bullet train würden die
sicherheitssysteme aktiv
das ist das body in klein system es
neigt den zug etwas
kurven nehmen wie ein profi dank
innovativer technologie ganz einfach
sie zeigt mir wie man anhält neben nach
unten ok und jetzt die bremse
sie sind am bahnhof von nagoya
angekommen
der nächste zug könnte den
schienenverkehr revolutionieren weil er
gar keine schienen braucht
der markt ist einer magnetschwebebahn
und mit bis zu 500 kilometern pro stunde
fast doppelt so schnell wie der finanzen
[Musik]
die technologie des metlife ist
unglaublich supraleitende spulen lassen
in schweben und beschleunigen ihn
die führungs bahn des marktes ist von
supraleitenden elektromagnetisch polen
gesäumt das schwebe system hebt ihn 10
cm in die höhe das antriebssystem
katapultiert ihn nach vorne
das modell zeigt uns wie es funktioniert
zurzeit wird der markt noch getestet
aber ab 2027 soll er in betrieb gehen
[Musik]
nach hause
wir nähern uns dem ziel unserer reise
neben sind wir durch den bahnhof von
kyoto gefahren und den sechs minuten
sind wir schon in osaka
und ohne zweifel wir sind pünktlich
der shinkansen war der erste
hochgeschwindigkeitszug der welt
und ein halbes jahrhundert später
begeistert er uns immer noch
seine geheimnisse zu erkunden war
mindestens genauso spannend wie mit ihm
zu fahren
wilson hat mit ingenieuren gesprochen
und sogar selbst am steuer gesessen
für einen zug freak wie ihn ein
absoluter traum nur eine sache kann
dieses erlebnis noch übertreffen eine
fahrt im markt im jahr 2027
[Musik]